si quelqu'un me plaît je me transforme
en tchat ok c'est dans tu parles pendant
une heure d'interview epic arcs declan
juste un truc et vous faites comment la
chatte mais ne s'est pas passé comme ça
là c'est le choc et gère suis pas je dis
pas si je ne saisis séductrice mais
c'est le mec qui est en train de muter
remuer qu'ils aient cette séductrice
on vous voit ouais ouais je suis pas
enfin je sais pas je sens terrien si je
sais à quoi répond que vous avez du
succès moi je sais alors moi je vais
vous dire tous les à l'histoire
je vous jure que c'est vrai tous mes
copains appelé pour parler de la tenue
de jennifer s'était il parlait même pas
de l'émission elle danse là et j'adore
ce look mois ah ouais franchement
jennifer venez on va partir sur un
garçon a look comme ça sur un théâtre
elle respirait pas moi c'est vrai ça va
pas du tout mais vraiment zelaya doit
les prendre car son nom de famille wang
ou ya un cheval blonde mais toi tu te
fais jamais de délires capillaires du
reste de ta paix quelques-uns ah oui
c'est vrai j'ai été rousse vénitienne
pendant trois jours il n'y a pas
longtemps sur sur la vie de ma mère
ouais c'est mon fantasme en fait d'être
blonde platine mais je suis resté deux
jours comme ça tu as ta patrie fait
l'impossible vous savez que c'est
l'effet - jour ou au seuil pas ouais
offert au blond aussie vous avez fait et
ferrou j'étais encore sur des parents et
je suis passé devant la chambre de mes
parents et à ma mère qui était mon père
si tu avais vu ce que je viens de voir
et vous vous faites quoi vu jennifer je
vais sortir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bête
non non c'est bête parce que je voulais
reparler de ma déclaration album de
jenifer malheureusement je vais plus
parler du livre de patrick politique je
sors flip attend jean michel maire tient
jean michel maire pour la vie bonne nuit
jamais personne à la télé parfois mais
donc du coup pour la coiffe et dire qu
un coût non non
j'adore et délicat parce qu'elle a
trouvé une pancarte a fait du coup non
non c'est quoi donc là parce que je
l'adoré c'est mais bon ça se voit et ça
non
jennifer jennifer ce qui me prend
qu'elle doit essayer vous sur le volet
ce que j'ai une très très belle surprise
quand est ce que vous savez est ce que
vous savez qu'ils sont océane brunel
maylis et anaïs ce sont des gens qui
comptent beaucoup pour vous d'univers
d'accord est ce que vous savez de qui il
s'agit océane brunel maylis anaïs brunel
ça ne fait rien je connais les autres
prénoms des personnages il vous ne les
connaissais pas vraiment il rêvait de
vous voir en vrai font partie d'une
association qui nous tient énormément à
coeur dans touche pas à mon poste et
dont vous êtes la marraine à leur fille
le refuge
exactement merci de les accueillir ils
sont venus avec olivier serge et aurélie
thill sont bénévoles auront plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce
auj